an attendant jazzes up the safety
instructions you guys have that video
can we play it it's awesome
the safety information card place the
vest over your head
wrap the strap around your waist
look at this guy
he's awesome
do you see what this guy's doing okay so
this is an important lesson
and i love this video because this is a
guy who's just living life
we can get so bogged down in stress in
oh i don't feel good oh this your head
can go to a dark place real fast oh my
god look what's going on in the world it
feels divisive oh this person doesn't
like me that person was nasty to me
negative thoughts are so powerful if you
allow them to be the reason i love this
video is because this guy he made the
most of that moment maybe he's inside
maybe he's bored doing that every flight
maybe he's like you know what but he
decided you know what i'm not gonna make
this a boring job i'm gonna spice it up
i'm gonna do something fun he decided he
was gonna make other people laugh you
hear the laughter on that plane
laughter's contagious that puts smiles
on so many faces what a beautiful moment
also he's funny as all hell i guarantee
you i'm saying it now you heard it here
first that guy's gonna do that on a
flight and someone's gonna be in the
audience and someone's gonna see him and
be like i should hire that guy for x y
and z he's gonna get a job performing
he's gonna maybe that's what he's trying
to do maybe he's saying i wanna get into
something else i'm gonna put my best
foot out there
he also looks a guy like a guy that's
enjoying his job
maybe he's not enjoying it i don't know
but he's making the most of it right
he's smiling he's making you smile what
an important message and i always say to
people
life can get so overwhelming
but you get one life right
so maybe today like you wake up and it
sucks right you get up you're like oh
this is going on and i don't know i
don't have beef jerky in the house i'm
in a bad mood i do that sometimes or
like oh my kid i'm going through right
now to share with you my kid won't sleep
parents out there by the way if you have
some help all of a sudden we change him
to a toddler bed he's excited about it
for a week
now he won't sleep in it apparently
everything in the room got scary
instantly like everything on the wall i
had to take all the pictures down he
doesn't like the clock he picked out
everything's wrong so i'm like as a mom
i'm like what do i do i bring him in the
bed with me he don't want to be in bed
with me he decides he just does he's
like no i want to leave the room so i
don't i'm like
it's one of those weeks right so i could
easily just be like ugh i didn't sleep
this is going wrong that's going wrong
you have to make a choice in life things
are going to go wrong things are going
to get hard subscribe don't forget
things are going to get hard
but you have to like make the most of
the moment this guy's an inspiration to
me and tell me if you're sitting out
there let's say you hate to fly would
you rather be on a flight with someone
who did the standard or
whatever that is or did this
i guarantee you everyone's going to say
give me this guy he seems like a lot of
fun also
a guy like this seems like a great guy
to work with when you want to work with
a guy like that always seems to be like
bringing something fun to the table
so my point is your day may start off
shitty there might be something going on
in your life that's not good just make a
decision to find some light
and to bring it to other people if you
like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here